[Musique]
non
voilà
écolo fait monsieur david kiely des
couleurs avec les blancs le vainqueur de
cette partie remportera le bac
voilà donc levé la main si vous nous
entendez
voilà merci ça permet de contrôler que
tout va bien alors c'est parti c'est une
défense sicilienne qu'on le voit
toujours peu comme la première vraie oui
oui oui l évidence il ya d'accidents
kamel mario resca les non c'est pas tout
à fait pareil là juifs ou gsm cool de
jouer la route avec f3 mais il revient
il revient là il a fallu jouer quand
même ici au lieu des 33
tout à l'heure ils étaient là revoilà
voit la halle 6 foule 3 h 5
voilà on peut l'on salue comme la
présence de monsieur crespo qui est venu
qui est vice président du conseil
général voilà qu'on voit ici conseil
général partenaire de cet événement
depuis trois ans puis sa reprise en 2005
et qui a permis à des centaines de
jeunes de venir assister à cet événement
communication pour l'événement ayant
démarré dès le mois de janvier dans les
championnats des jeunes scolaires ainsi
que les championnats officiels de la
fédération pour annoncer le soutien du
conseil général
qui donc invite les jeunes dans sa
politique tous au stade
le conseil général soutient les sports
en gironde en invitant notamment les
jeunes assister aux grands événements
sportifs de gironde donc le football le
basket
enfin tous les sports et donc aussi les
échecs qui sont sport voilà depuis l'an
2000 dans ce type de rencontre en voit
vraiment le côté sportif du jeu d'échecs
avec des regrets on voit avec des jeunes
comme on voit que les jeunes a
maintenant en france on a donc des
jeunes comme romain edouard 16 ans
champion d'europe il faut rappeler quand
même qu'il ya trente ans en france il y
avait aucun titre et et qu'aujourd'hui
on a vingt grands maîtres internationaux
et une quarantaine ou une cinquantaine
de mètres internationaux dont romain et
doit donc champion d'europe et donc
mathieu cornette la grande surprise de
ce grand prix qui étaient invités pour
la première fois qu'ils viennent de
bordeaux qui est le premier maître
international bordelais et qui a créé
peut-être la plus grande surprise de ce
tournoi tout à l'heure en éliminant
laurent frayssinet il a éliminé deux
grands maîtres tout simplement hier le
grand maître olivier rené est
aujourd'hui le grand maître laurent
frayssinet alors dans cette deuxième
manche et donc on rappelle que la
première partie a vu romain edouard et
alberto navire à david se quitter sur le
partage du point donc cette partie est
décisive
le vainqueur est qualifié pour la grande
finale face à matthew cornette à 22h01
rappelle qu'à 20 heures durant le match
pour la troisième place où laurent
frayssinet affrontera et bien le perdant
de ce match là pour la troisième place
importante qu'en voyant le podium
toujours
et après la grande grande finale pour
clôturer ce grand prix 2007 à 22 heures
mathieu cornette face à alberto david ou
face à romain edouard qui va affronter
mathieu connaître pour succéder quand
même palmarès tout à fait exceptionnel
on va leur rappeler 1 et prendre la
suite de cartes peuvent c'est pas rien
il ya eu voilà il ya eu karpov champion
du monde en 2005 qui est venue remporté
ce grand prix il ya eu aussi alexei
shirov carthéry quatrième joueur mondial
à l'époque loyers des baux joueurs mais
peter l'écho vice champion du monde qui
avait perdu contre la dmr kramnik son
match il ya eu un mec que la dame ce qui
était 5e joueur mondial aussi quand il
était le meilleur joueur de grande
bretagne et l'an dernier il ya eu un
grand grand match entre laurent
frayssinet et paco ballero qui est aussi
un des meilleurs joueurs du monde le
meilleur joueur espagnol l'union
espagnole pas qu'on va lire repensé qui
fait partie aussi des meilleurs mondiaux
laurent frayssinet faisant partie des 50
meilleurs mondiaux mais c'est surtout
aussi le grand maître aquitain le seul
grand maître en aquitaine pour l'instant
savoir comme aquitaine pour l'instant
donc seul laurent frayssinet mathieu
cornette ont réussi à passer la barre de
la maîtrise la foulée 5e cornette qui
maintenant est partie au club de cannes
pour continuer sa carrière
donc c'est dommage d'ailleurs qu'à
bordeaux on puisse pas renault on ne
peut pas par faute de moyens financiers
pour garder des bons joueurs il faut
pouvoir les payer parce que ces joueurs
deviennent des professionnelles et ne
peuvent plus jouer au niveau oui joue en
étant amateur avec tous les jours de ce
dangereux sont des professionnels en
fait il est professionnel pour jouer
dans les clubs doivent être payés et les
clubs s'ils n'ont pas dead importante
leur municipalité ou
deux des associés du monde des
collectivités
ben doivent trouver d'autres ressources
qui sont pas faciles même le mécénat
mais c'est pas c'est un peu limité du
sud rail
donc c'est oui c'est dommage que les
quatre en ville comme bordeaux il n'est
pas l'équivalent de deux clubs qui a
comme dans des villes comme cannes comme
lyon comme comme paris comme paris bien
sûr et d'autres huiles et strasbourg et
c'est bon mais il ya le grand prix de
bordeaux contre cas pareils oui ça c'est
bien mais c'est une initiative qui a par
ailleurs alors il ya trente doit
stéphane c'est pas attaque du cavalier
ou 5
il faut que ça parte de quelque part
bien sûr attaque le cavalier regardez le
cavalier tâche à bien placé pour le
savoir
le cavalier est attaqué on rappeler à 1
renault que alors les chansons de léo
s'il ya le championnat aquitaine rapide
demain pour tous les joueurs qui ont
envie de mettre en pratique ce qu'ils
ont appris lors de ce grand prix de
bordeaux c'est demain au 36 rue buhan à
partir de 10 heures 36 rubis assis à
côté du lycée montaigne très beau club
d'échecs dans bordeaux le plus beau un
des plus beaux de france d'ailleurs
inquiets qui existent moi de tout ce que
j'ai vu c'est un très très bon local qui
donne sur la sur la rue avec des vitres
un vitrage qui donne sur la rue très
très beau local qui va accueillir deux
championnats d'aquitaine rapide demain
dimanche
donc pour mettre en pratique tout ce
qu'on a appris ici tout ce qui rendait
des mains du géant dans les doigts voilà
pour aller moi j'ai noté parce que je
changeais assister tous et renault assez
assez grand grand prix aussi qu'avait
qui ont initié un peu cette saillie mot
papa voilà mon parent et javel
je me rappelle que j'avais joué
justement des tournois après avoir vu
ses profits aux parents et aux joues
mieux bien sûr parce que jamais inscrit
en scène près n'y a découlé des grands
maîtres et grands champions mais ça dure
pas un cd oui mais ces cds modèle
quelques fareins quand on étudie les
échecs en étudie essentiellement les
deux parties des grands maîtres c'est à
dire de ceux qui ont qui ont compris des
choses du jeu d'échecs parleurs leur
talent et aussi par leur travail
alors là romain doit réfléchir où ils
amèneront cavaliers alors il peut le
mettre en danger catherine au gaz
naturel puisqu'il est protégé par le
plus ancien il ya plus de pions voilà
c'est pour l'attaqué c'est la case idéal
il ya plus de pions pour les cavaliers
il ya rien on ne peut pas attaquer ce
cavalier donc qui va ils auront du mal à
le déloger les blancs voilà la quasi
d'alain cavalier je le rappelle c'est
une case de préférence dans le camp
ennemi
donc ici sur la quatrième rangée y
visiter avec les noirs et que cette case
ne soit pas chassables par un pion ce
qui est le cas pour la case et g4 à
neige ou comme intermédiaires
il joue un coup intermédiaires ri aux
remises pour ouvrir les lignes voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe
absolument ils ouvrent les lignes c il
faut jouer sur dame prend il y aura
carlier prend 4 je pense a pu être donc
donc ici belle phase tactique pour
ouvrir les lignes sur le grand roque un
court terme le grand roque des blancs
donc là il attaque de edward au lieu de
défendre le cavalier donc les noirs en
contre-attaqué ici avec b 4 cavaliers
ici et donc les blancs ont pris
cavaliers et hop ça est repris de
l'autre côté donc en fait on peut aussi
effectivement défendre indirectement de
pièces en attaquant une autre pièce pour
wifi c'est un coup thématiques
c'est à dire le coupé quatre pour
rouvrir pour attaquer attaquer le roi
je réfléchis alors si pu comprendre
celles qu'on peut jouer le coup
cavaliers ces six attaques la dame et le
foot ne peut pas prendre pourquoi
et bien parce que la tour ici maintenant
après pourrez vous fait la dame
non mais là il ya aussi cavalier prend
1,4 chez les noirs attaque la dame on ne
craint pas faux prince est alors de
l'intermédiaire cavaliers prend ses
trois échecs
on a va explique qu'ils ont expliqué
donc la menace ici poussé peut-être car
il prend 1,4 oui attaque la dame avec
échec
donc on peut pas faire un coup
intermédiaire lorsqu'il y aura échec
pour réparer l'échec et donc beaucoup
intermédiaire serait une faute
donc il sur calais prend 4 il faudrait
dans ce cas là bouger la dame rouge et
la dame de manière à défendre la casse
g5 parce que lecavalier puis aux quatre
attaques le fou g5 une deuxième fois
mais mais si si romain edouard réfléchit
c'est que ça doit pas être si évident
dans peut-être il manque quelque chose
qu'on n'aurait pas vu qu'elle les prend
1,4 si l'on prend aux sept attaquants la
dame
eh bien ça me cavaliers français gabala
rang avec échec puis faut prendre le
cavalier voilà et ensuite on reprend le
fou en reprend le fou en allemagne et
une dame voilà donc c'est pas possible
car il prend 4 semble un bon coup quand
on prendra le fou avec le cavalier sans
doute voyez ça a l'air bien mais
peut-être que les blancs en prônant
ensuite en gsm couvert les colonnes et
le roi noir ne peut plus rock et voilà
c'est c'est le seul inconvénient de
toute cette suite à ses couleurs ou en
noir est encore au centre un groupe et
que finalement il n'y a eu de gagner que
met donc alors qu'un pion il faut
réfléchir à l'autre variante trop long
puis on prend 1,5
il est possible aussi lorsque la manche
propose qu'avait laissé six ne peut pas
prendre le cavalier puisque tours
pendables
hélas dans ce cas la dame par exemple
c'est cette attaque le cavalier est sûre
cavaliers grand fou on échange d'abord
les dames et ensuite à friction prend
dames on prend enfin le cavalier
donc je pense que romain edouard calculs
ces lignes là il doit qu elle ces deux
variantes plus possible sans doute alors
rarement quand on rate encore décernés
dire je sais pas si elle policiers 8,8
possible attention ces mythes possible
quel est l'intérêt de ceux qui
m'attaquent la dame aurait alors donné
aux candidats cavale prendre 4 ou alors
deuxième possibilité
puis on prend environ pour moi je
préfère cavaliers prend 4 j'sais pas
pourquoi parce que je vais prendre le
fou g5 et puis on n'a pas envie
effectivement que vous voyez à ouvrir la
ligne par ziad avant la date pour dams
ici en plus mais nos calculs on se dit
que c'est que c'est risqué si on rate un
truc on peut la perdre à partir de coupe
donc il faut vraiment évaluer quelle va
être la position à la sortie de la ligne
donc soit puis on prend 2,5 soit qu'avec
34 il faut tout calculer comprendre cinq
cavaliers ces six attaques la dame
ensuite on va prendre le coup et sept
puis jouer n 5
voilà et sinon non papa ya le clan des
six qui sera ne sert à leila pahlavi 57
et les cafés comme ami l'a fait qu'il
n'est pas fiscalisée sicile alors qu'à
venir 3 qui tout de suite qui menacent
évident qu'ils laissent la tour face à
la dame et qui menacent le simple
cavalli prendre 5 qui gagnent quasiment
une plaie est ce parce que le foot 17 ne
pourra pas s'échapper avec touré
cavaliers devant mais c'est au nord de
jouer toujours pas de cavalier prend 1,4
la menace la menace existe à il va en
fait il veut il veut
laissez le roi noir au centre un là les
noirs peuvent par ok ils n'ont pas le
temps imaginons le petit rocquelin petit
rock pour vous car il prend 1,5
oui nos installations d'essai est ce que
font les noirs la scène d'une pièce par
fou prendre cavaliers puis on ferait
d'abord vous prendriez les limites
défense a roulé c'est le fou at a créé
adam derrière attaquerez la dame pas mal
on peu rauque est compliqué un peu
rauque et salers salaires possible même
si même si même si ses choux bon il
prend 1,4 à shanghai prend d'un charisme
parce que c'est le matériel et ou 5 ivan
henry prend 1,4 bon c'est logique
comme promis 5 est ce qu'il a prévu ça
oui sans doute
l'emprunt 5 atteint science et c'est un
classique ça attention le roi rester au
centre
le roi est au centre bien sûr les pièces
sont pas coordonnées chez les noirs à
cause du retard de développement
attention attention alberto david e
s'ils lancent une attaque forte pourrait
l'emporter très vite dans ce type de
position cet hymne de position sont peut
faire mal très très très très très vite
avec le roi a tardé alors à noter que là
les noirs pourri par exemple on voit la
fourchette évidemment la fourchette ici
attaques de tous mais il y avait des
menaces
pire les dames prendre les sept il y
avait des projets 7 et la tourache 8 été
attaqué derrière il ya eu une attaque
énorme il y avait une recette à quoi
donc la qualité en ne comptait plus
c'était ont visé le roi donc ils
héroïque rien réussi ce romano
il essaie de regrouper ces pièces c'est
pas mal de garder son pion de plus c est
qu il a capté 6 6 peuvent se le garder
c'est pas mal puisque maintenant que la
dame étant le simple cavalier a capté
deux pions donc je vais type pas y aller
en cinq
il n'a pas capté de pioncer égalité
matérielle mais ses qualités parce que
là il avait il ya deux pions de plus ici
et les noirs ici on deux pions ici avec
le plus c'est ça donc quatre courts 2
est ici 3 comprend donc égalité 2-2 puis
en position par contre complètement
asymétrique par opposition asymétrique
asymétrique donc petit rock sans doute
prochain
pour les noirs le grand roque ici ici
donc c'est par contre semblerait que le
roi blanc est plus aérée il ya des
colonies si oui alors que le roi noir il
serait plus à l'abri mais d'un autre
côté pour l'instant pour l'instant il ya
une tour qui est très pénible puisque
les loups le vous dm le fou les pièces
et noir sont passives
il n'y a pas de pièces noires active et
ferment pièces blanches mais par quoi
est ce que l'intérêt de la voirie entre
nous c'est que la dame est enceinte on
peut pas jouer cavalier ou cinq qui
aurait ajouté de la pression oui la dame
prend la caisse du cavalier c'est
embêtant on aurait préféré mettre le
cavalier en hausse 1 bien sûr mais bon
c'est pas ça pas été possible oui mais
par contre il ya des il a joué près
zellik des possibilités d'attac à base
d'oeuf ou les trois plus tard et puis il
faut preuve si c'est et la taxe sur les
cases blanches 6,6 à petit rock avec g4
et l'ouverture de des lignes sur le sur
le roi noir quand il se sera abritée par
le petit rock
à noter aussi on a pas il considère le
conseil régional aussi partenaire
historique de l'évènement depuis depuis
2005 soutient activement le le grand
prix non mais c'est une très bonne chose
qui est bien nos grandes vitrines des
échecs sur bordeaux en plein centre
ville avec ce tournoi dans un lieu comme
ça ma vie qu'avec l' échiquier murale
est aussi sud-ouest un grand média
régional le plus grand sans doute qui
soutient alors là depuis le début aussi
avec qu'on l'a vu cette semaine
beaucoup d'articles sur le grand prix
des pleines pages comme aujourd'hui dans
l'édition de bordeaux il ne pleine page
sur les matchs d'hier alors qu'il y
avait un portrait de mathieu cornette
ray ray qui tombait à pic puisque
mathieu cornette et donc qualifié pour
cette grande finale superbe qu'on attend
ce soir à 22h complètement inattendus
mathieu cornette qui était vraiment
outsider mais que bien que les romains à
bordeaux découvert dans une école de
bordeaux etc qui maintenant donc joué à
cannes joue à cannes
celle inverse c'est à dire que zidane
joue à cannes il veut aborder et pour
mathieu cornette il jouait à bordeaux il
est parti un quartier chic and peut-être
le futur zidane des échecs matu cornette
il a dit qu'il a des qualités en tout
cas c'est les victoires qui donne
confiance la confiance ça compte aussi
beaucoup bien sûr important bien sûr le
moral et pour ça fait deux fois qu'il
bloque ari balogh ans fascinée cette
année il avait joué pour la première
fois face à lui en partie officielle
cette année
alors voilà coup car les d4 un coup
intéressant toujours améliorer toujours
améliorer les pièces et des petrosyan
qui montrait son incidence est parti
c'était un grand champion pour ça mais
qu'il avait une pièce un peu mal placé
sans souci était de l'améliorer mais
combinaison arrivé après tout seul dès
que les pièces et des mieux placés donc
dès qu'on décèle une pièce mal placés en
anglais
l'idée simple c'est jouer cavalier c6
voilà donc il ne permet pas ils vous
donnent des huit ans maintenant car ici
c'est plus possible on peut prendre la
dame n'est plus en 18 donc la tour ici
attaque dans le vide
j'ai joué dans des huit à briller face à
ses charges et les dames propose un
échange donc bien joué de la part de
romain doit décharger quand même soulagé
la position il m'est précieux honneur au
manoir depuis hier je le connaissais pas
du tout c'est si grande maturité pour
son jeune âge en tout cas on voit le
flair de l'organisation d'avoir insulté
mathieu cornette et de romain edouard
yassir ornans doubs r2 grande surprise
et de beaux joueurs dont la gouaille qui
donne la vie à leurs pièces du grand
prix de bordeaux soutient les joueurs
régionaux comme laurent frayssinet comme
mathieu cornette qui sont invités en
priorité évidemment par rapport aux
autres stars mondiales
voilà alors ce retard de développement
des huit noir et donc il essaie de
compenser ça en proposant les charges
des dames
quand les dames disparaissent bons les
résultats que son sens moins virulente
on va parler un peu du circuit aussi
puisque on parle beaucoup de ses joueurs
internationaux cercle international
jouit il ya quelques très très grand
tournoi c'est un peu l'équivalent des
roland garros des échecs aussi au niveau
des parties lentes
ça c'est des parties rapides le grand
prix de bordeaux était classé 10e
rencontre mondiale en 2005 des parties
rapides mais des parties lentes les plus
grands tournois du monde sont linares
chorus dortmund ou le tournoi de sofia
qui a lieu d'ailleurs actuellement et
qui sont des tournois qui liste qui
invite à peu près les dix meilleurs du
monde et qui distribue à peu près
quelque chose comme 300 mille euros de
prix trois cent mille euros de prix pour
les meilleurs mondiaux
aujourd'hui numéro un mondial étant
depuis le mois d'avril vi va l'atteindre
à nantes lundi hamdiya qui reprend son
titre de numéro un qu'il avait déjà eu
et qui le reprend 1 topalov le bulgare
qui depuis qu'il a perdu son titre face
aux russes kramnik a du mal à revenir et
que notre français numéro 1 tienne
bacrot lui il est en train d'essayer de
revenir un peu dans la course parce que
l'an dernier l'état invité dans les plus
grands tournois du monde mais il n'avait
pas réussi à confirmer
oui mais cette année il a il a plu a
plus d'invitation alors voilà les
charges des dames voilà tout reprendre
d'un procès est une décision assez bien
son nom officiel pouvait la prendre
c'est bien le joueur des
des blancs j'échange où je garde encore
les dames
mais la dame en b 8 et est active sur la
colonne verte voit la colonne la wii si
la dame se sent levée de 2,5 il y avait
foule à troyes s'est emporté par exemple
en droit à nos maillots et parfois 3 6 1
et 3 mais si on essaye pas la croire et
bien on en effet non mais dans le
programme promet fallait pas qu'il aille
à la toile à l'époque il y en a trois à
neutre wall e avec la dame donc ici il a
repris de la tour bien sûr alors le
problème moi j'ai peur aux renault sait
qu'on va perdre encore ce pion fou prend
1,6 menace un tout simplement c'est
quand même pénible parce que ça va faire
quand même trois groupes y ont passé
voilà que ça y est moi j'ai l'impression
que les blancs sont mieux ça y est les
blancs les blancs droits usuels davance
trois pions passé lié à l'or c'est
l'autre est brisé ouais ils sont passés
pourquoi parce qu'il ya pas de plus en
phase regardez les noirs eux n'ont qu'un
seul pion passer ses pions et ce que
même le pion effet pas passé puisque le
plonger pour l'arrêter passera ici
passera pas sur cette case par contre le
pion aux lui n'a pas de pions en face
mais là il y en a trois et trois pions
pas s'il y est j'ai un seul problème ces
lettres de voir le roi hallejuah dernier
énorme qui a aussi trois colonnes
ouverte sur le revoilà donc ces médias
puis d'amalia plus les dames la taxe
aura moins fort la taxe sera moins forte
les pieds en voir avancée qui
sembleraient tous les blancs sorte et
m'emmenait des problèmes aux pièces
noires oui exactement
oui donc gain d'un pion viennent d'un
pion pour les blancs alors est ce que
les noirs réfléchissent à petit rock
sans doute sans doute je crois que ça
leur possible un jeu je vois pas de
problème là cavalier cas liés aux quatre
cavalières quatre souffrent ainsi va
prendre du roi évident là il est résolu
le problème du rock
il va prendre du roi je croyais pas
coûts intermédiaires c'était pour
résoudre les problèmes du rock
la menace c'est ça va ce sera quand même
après oui parce que le cavaliere 4 a
menacé cavaliers ses trois échecs
ces trois lycéens meadow qu'ils gagnent
c'était la menace
l'idée mais il a pris l'option recettes
dont il a pris le fossé ce serait le
défaut et c'est donc ce serait deux
pièces non oui sur cavaliers ces trois
quarts et ses trois échecs
oui roi c'est un cavani parents et le
fou s'enlève et les gens lèvent le
cavalier donc une qualité plus mais le
fou pourrait venir en d6 contre leur
camp la tour il ya le cavalier encore
oui il allait cette fois que j'ai oligan
qualité très jolie un bisou fébrile le
fait pas alors il prend devait y avoir
un truc que j'ai pas bu oui mais tous
tombés 6 à la sortie qui qu'il faut que
je tenais de fou oui mais justement
c'est les noirs qui peuvent jouer calice
et 3 comme les c3 échec
oui france est un oui mais oui cavale et
prend est ce que le fou pouvait empêcher
le cavalier sortir je sais pas qu'est ce
qui se passe sur food et 6 il y avait
tout b6 attaque les deux ans une
variante assez compliqué oui mais
peut-être il s'est dit que la tourache 8
était enfermée donc ici audace cavaliers
ces trois-là y ait une menace directe
il préfère pas prendre la qualité mais
libéré sa tour mais là il menace car les
deux aussi et cavaliers pts 2 il faut
que jamais il faut parler de menaces
alors on peut parler de menaces run ou
tout simplement jouant par exemple
tourne toi voilà comme ça la tour sur
calais ses trois échecs on peut pas
prendre évidemment avec les blancs
pourquoi parce que les huit ici entre le
lhb deux là si on prenait on sera en
échec donc c'est interdit et sur la lys
3 échecs par exemple 3 1 ou froissé un
plus tôt richard le hir des prades
chèques seront là ce roi donc tout va
bien pour eux boileau emerson qui
menacent cavaliers f5 aussi parce qu'il
faut voir les contrevenants sont comme
tout rage 3 qui permettrait de contrôler
la tendance et cavalières de cavalaire
deux camps maj 3 damas et ont fait la
fourchette sur la case h3 et sur la
casse d un donc need a doctor le coup
préconiser mécanisée parce qu'il a aussi
la menace cavaliers f5 pour renvoyer le
roi sur la 8e et donc couper les tours
de leur liaison
lorsque le cavalier aura bougé lorsque
le guerrier noir aura bouge donc là le
cam a dit attaquer tout de suite car il
était avec la menace tout reprend
cavaliers c'est ça oui alors on peut
jouer tourbe et 6 contre attaquer sur le
x 6 de manière à risque et ce genre de
choses à prendre le fou contre le
cavalier sur tourcoing c'est pas bien
non c'est pas beaucoup puisque un
recueil les c3 surtout messi se renvoyer
le foin voilà pour envoyer le roi un
perdant voilà oui bien joué joliment
bien sûr l'idée cavaliers on faisait 8
et le x 6 étaient cloués au réel ferait
joli petit point une tactique des coups
de pattes tactique des jeunes et romain
lejeune robin voilà bien le cavalière et
y accueille les latéraux il vient
d'éliminer mine de rien un pion un
dangereux de l'ale dame exactement très
bien très bien joué bien du joli petit
phase tactique il un des mines un pion
qui rétablit les clips matériel que nous
n'avions pas vu et que lui n'a pas raté
donc là on s'attend pour laquelle ces
six le seul coup échec alors le coup a
lancé pour envoyer le roi sur la 8ème à
- crouch roi m6 est roi m6 j'ai vu ça
tout de suite on est rétabli terrible
vous voyez cavaillé les six pilotes
auraient fait des échéant mena tour
échec gagner le peuple cette tour échec
pour le pion à vii est attaqué par la
tour et par lequel non ça c'était l'idée
de thorens était d'envoyer le roi gêner
la liaison détour envoyez le roi sans la
8e
cavalier échec on peut pas prendre
évidemment pourquoi parce que la tour
plein attaque le roi je fais comme les
hommes politiques oui oui je fais
pourquoi après ça c'est que je dis un
truc je dis pourquoi leur truc
pourquoi pour pouvoir avoir plus de
temps de parole à les laisser avec 6,6
donc il va y avoir cavaliers deux des
six je pense puis avec la menace tour f1
menace tour
voilà donc il revient en rien de cette
maladie propose nul ça va peut-être
avant nul de reddition audition 2 nuls 7
minutes contre 7 minutes 10
elles sont ici on est nul après tout je
sens que la finale est pas forcément ma
faveur dit lenoir
on va parler de pions on va rappeler la
règle c'est lié à la règle on voit plus
la règle renault de répétition des coups
mais voilà si la position est répétée
trois fois j'ai deux ou trois fois
c'est nul là il a proposé nul alberto je
les ai vus il a proposé nu leurs mains
doigts réfléchi six minutes si on répète
trois fois la position c'est nul donc là
apparemment les blancs essaient de
répéter la position et ses mémoires
jouer f6 le noir un joueur web 6-1 et
pulse et elle a du mal à proposer une
priorité s'il accepte nul on aura des
bistrots 2000 mais pour refuser faut
qu'ils jouent à autre chose bref si
c'est oui mais le seul coup sirois et
fuite comme un bouquet pâte est pas beau
qui est pas bon roi et fuient des
travaux parce que ça enferme la toile
voilà les joujoux yayi il veut jouer il
veut jouer il veut jouer
il n'a pas peur le gamin il veut jouer
parce qu'ils soient neufs ou amis pour
revenir à cette mesure
il a refusé la nulle c'est changer rien
cherché faire quelque chose il sait que
les blancs veulent annuler donc il peut
très bien revenir en cette api psol
psychologiquement de refuser la nul à
l'adversaire qu'il a proposé c'est il
propose nul c'est bien d'autres composés
d'une loi ça y est c'est nul aura bon
d'accord d'accord il fournit alors la
halle avantages de la jeunesse peut-être
maintenant dans la partie ii rapide at
il dit
à suivre les deux joueurs ont convenu
d'une partie du depuis ce que vous avez
vu la position assez répété trois fois
une position se répète trois fois
condition qu'il y ait exactement les
mêmes possibilités de jeu à chaque fois
ce qui était bien le cas ici donc nous
aurons droit au bliss de départage cinq
minutes par joueur
[Musique]
les tyrans
autre quitté renault
put jeu d'échecs et excite
[Musique]
voilà donc
monsieur d'ailleurs c'était
six arbitres je crois que si si c'est
bon tu habites bien avoir et blanc dont
qu'il aie a de nouveau les blancs ou sur
le lien
si jamais il y à égalité presque bis de
départage nous aurons huit cents alors
bien sûr les joueurs relève les manches
pour ne pas être gêné par les éléments
julie pendouiller qui pourrait renverser
les pièces voilà on retire au rock
brasse sur la couleur notez bien que
choisir les blancs et les noirs c'est
important larbitre expliquer des choses
voilà apparemment on a raté le début
qu'est ce qui se passe et ce qui s'est
passé un seul en main ce qu'est ce qui
se passe maintenant il faut arrêter il
faut arrêter le hall alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe est-ce qu'on voit la partie
julien on a un souci là je peux pourquoi
voilà ça y est c'est venu très bien
apparemment il ya eu une erreur de manip
loi la position est restée lente à égal
sur l'échiquier murale pas grave on est
maintenant on y est de nouveau donc
toujours toujours les sicilienne et
cette fois ci avec la variante dame b si
ce qui est une variante que jouer les
yougoslaves variantes des blitzer bien
sûr donc à leur tour de vis donc ça sera
deux blitz un après cette partie aura un
deuxième but et en cas d'égalité de ses
deux buts
là le bliss mort subite est décidément
ils nous mettent à rude épreuve
oui oh non c'est infernal on est presque
dans leur ouïe ouïe ouïe très dur que si
on passait pas toujours blida les
partage pas de repos on n'a pas en elle
qu'un seul match fini
au bout du match normal c'était le match
de frayssinet hier 17h c'est maintenant
attention voilà il veut empêcher il a
empêché les blancs de jouer eux mêmes le
kw/h si ce corps est un peu détruit sa
structure un roumain edward qui joue h6
et il attaque le fuji 5 où va ce fou et
il devient ou le fouga de la diagonale
pour d'éventuels sacrifice un chat petit
rock donc cavalier ou 5 avec l'idée
cavaliers c4 un jour pour regagner la
paire de fou 2
pas la position de façon le blitz et
c'est surtout vers la fin que ça va se
décider
c'est vraiment l'histoire de rapidité
donc on reconnaît un la même structure
sicilienne on a eu droit qu'à des six
semaines dans ce match il ya eu 4 au
début c'est simple on voit que l'option
c5 a été échangé contre l'option des
quatre on reconnaît la structure
classique est toujours grand roque et
les noirs peut-être petit retard de leur
leur jouerie du rock ça y est maintenant
temps pour ces huit jours ont pas grand
comme tout cas oui bon il aurait pas
jouer dans cette position tour c'est 8 à
foix tap la dame
c'est un coup de blitz ça c'est un coup
là vraiment typique pour faire réfléchir
à l'attention sur dame 6,6 il faut
trouver les cavaliers à 5 il faut
trouver la case de la dam dam et 8 voilà
très souvent la dame sur ce type
d'attaqué ça va embellir noir à la fois
cette houle alors est ce que c'est bien
ça propose là nul et oui même si c'est
ça la rend je remets doit rêver ça va
être nul wii propose nul propose nul
avec les noirs et ensuite et bien il va
tenter sa chance la profération y avait
peut-être à bertoua dit t'as pas envie
de jouer envie de scott robin des toits
oui oui mais pourtant un nom nancy s'il
la joue il revient en d4
romain edouard est très à l'aise en bits
mais il joue beaucoup sur internet des
partis de très très rapide une deux une
minute par joueur voire même de qu'une
seconde par contre à wil à celle qui
sait jouer des parties très vite ici
jouer les bons coups c'est faire perdre
autant l'adversaire
le temps est plus important puisque
quasiment presque l'escaut l'échiquier
on peut dire qu'une minute d'avancé ça
vaut une pièce oui oui c'est ça vaut une
pièce si vous avez une minute d'avancé
au blitz ça vaut quasiment une pièce
c'est un facteur très important c'est un
facteur essentiel facteur premier public
ça va jouer les échecs perdent de leur
valeur stratégique quand on fait les
blés disney
alors pour j'évite le roi va rester au
centre
le roi va rester au centre pour mémoire
ça c'est pas très oui mais ça va je
pense et ça va forcer salle de rcr à
réfléchir à prendre du temps ouvert
cavaliers pour aller le chercher une c4
parce que sur france vous pensé quand on
est content peut-être de prendre du
pillon la wii l'ouvrir la colombe et
bien sûr est ce que la vaillance et 4 il
quand même pénible
il peut aller en b 6 puis à 4 jours peut
choisir aussi pourquoi pas de revenir en
décédant je pense qu'il va aller en c4
je pense qu'ils valaient en c4 c'est un
coût qui provoque un il le fait au live
et ses 4 attention très pénible ce
courant des menaces de carrelet prend b2
souvent pour l'instant ça va le cas les
c3 est défendue par le fou par la dame
mais ça peut être un thème oulala alors
5 il faut pour les blancs ouvrir le plus
vite possible des lignes au centre donc
5 est un très bon coup parce qu'ils
attaquent une pièce tard et qu'il est
sûr après la présente des six il est sûr
qu'une ligne au moins va sourire au
centre qu'est ce qui va faire donc
d'apprendre du cul on voit la sélection
alors que font les noirs un coup comme
cavalier 17 un coup comme qu'à valider
cinq pourquoi pas pour faire pression
sur lequel un quart des 5 une belle case
salariés ou 4 aussi bataille des cinq
belles cases voilà il suffit de regarder
les possibilités
oui oui et sur cavale et poincaré on
prendrait du fou évidemment pas du pion
oui surtout pas sur veut pas mourir
on va pas ouvrir les lignes a donné un
puits en libre le pied en libre des
années minel qu'il faut contrôler j'ai
peur pour alberto parce que romain
edouard a l'air très très à l'aise en
blitz
ça serait alors ça serait la finale de
la jeunesse extraordinaire si on avait
une finale les douars mathieu qu'honnête
avec le prévenu qui avait au départ
qui aurait parié ça au début oui oui
c'était en donner l'avantagé aux joueurs
l'expérience mais la cadence rapide
favoriser la jeunesse on l'a lacava
lieutenant qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coup qui a valu à claques mois ci alors
on peut prendre aussi il ya aussi la
découverte sur le fou
ces six qui attaquent le cavalier au 4
mai le cas les os 4 étant prise voilà et
ensuite le pied en c2 sera cloué si le
pion si le le fou prend 1,4 et donc que
la tour et le fou se coordonner sur la
case ces deux on va expliquer sa renault
si vous prend 1,3 très important ou
prendre quatre tapez ici sur le pion ces
deux et on voit que derrière il ya bien
un tour il suffira de sortir ce cas
voilà une belle diagonale yan bin sicile
fou prend un échec avec une belle
diagonale de vie jusqu'à certains qui se
prolonge le scannage singer lefort kg le
repas jouer ça ou foot est roi donc ils
laissent la qualité il laisse la qualité
ou la la la qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coup encore à cette fourchette
voilà un thème f2 ça a été joué très
vite d'un prend qu'avaient les prend il
n'a pas pris date ou un avantage noir
oui oui avantage noir avantage moi j'ai
peur que les lidd appris le pion central
wailly défend f7 1 il fallait défendre
c'est triste parce que des fois il fait
le coup là mais ce n'était pas un coup
notre intention
les défenses est alors attention cavalli
prince et six donc il ya deux chasseurs
là sur l'échiquier intentions diato
chasseurs oui oui j'assure droits des
chasseurs de roi dame des 44 sion
moi au centre un titre sur les
avertissements un petit oeil sur
sécurité dans dix-sept mat avec la tour
ici mais pour l'instant le fou rire oui
maintenant des vaches et donc ce chaos
les boulangers 6 par exemple on ferait
fou prend échec par exemple des séries
du matin
mais là il est peut-être en train de
calculer les coûts comme on l'a déjà il
enlève à solers bon voilà donc il veut
changer voilà ça et romania comprimé
loire tours prend il faut soulager la
position quand on subit une attaque et
ce jour prennent vraiment que je prends
on comprend visas provisoires ce coup ou
la la attention il met le doigt sur la
faiblesse le psg ça du tout l'opposition
maintenant noir attention le pian et 6
oui là il a pris d'après voilà il avait
pris la raison c'était beaucoup trop
dangereux alors qu'un pion de plus pour
les noirs mais mais mais un roi baladeur
ça ici les basques à xinhua
il a fait un gros câlin il va enfin
trouver un abri on appelle sac à la main
on appelle ça le rock à la main dont
vous avez bien vu que là il était en
train de faire une césarienne il allait
le chercher
voilà ils ouvraient puis on prend et
dans un tourbillon prend 25 d'après ça
tient pas de problème apparent pour les
noirs ça va ça sauf le déséquilibre
torfou contre tours cavalier seul ces
cas mais attention à la attention
attention la case b2 mais voilà ils
veulent chasser tout de suite la
nouvelle cavaliers oui car les deux
chèques a bien su revenir aux quatre oui
bouche la colonne de l'adra l'attention
menace de récupérer les pions il reste
40 mois ces jeunes attention ça va
s'accélérer dans les 5 ou là la
fourchette
ça va très vite donc il défend
évidemment il va prendre le fou pour
attaquer touré fuite
l'échec tour c'est tout là la tension
attention il n'a pas pris le foule suit
attention au matin près ils font
attention aux mathes possible où la dame
18 foule n'a pas vu ça a très joli
on va prendre ce qui se passe là bas
c'est matt mais non j'ai pas matière à
27 12
le câble est en effet être cavaliers
temps h7 pardon le cas et en achetant
oui qu'est ce qui se passe t-il le cas
les temps et cette voix là il est revenu
en lice et voilà voilà on y est c'est
parce qu'il a du mal à le poser le
cavalier il a essayé les gagnants et les
gagnantes vingt et une secondes le temps
de mater il attendra t
il va aller voyez ça y est là il faut
qu'ils se serrent les petits ma
technique maintenant clos alors on y
parle à l'heure près par là c'est parce
qu'il est mal placé les wade à koriyama
des mal placés sur l'île ma technique
il est mal placé le roi et par là un
petit patch et la dame qui arrive
voilà c'est fini c'est madame voilà
c'est terminé non il est tombé autant en
fait tomber autant à tomber autant
remettez les pièces sur leurs cases on
mettait les pieds sur leurs cases
il est tombé autant partie d'une
remettez les dents et d'avoir case si on
peut remettre les pièces sur les diaz le
résulat retenu d'alors uma nul
alors évidemment comme les julia si on
peut mettre les pieds sur la case là et
qui nous disent qui s'est tenu sur les
bonnes cases nul
il est en bio temps avant de mater est
tombé autant julien tu m'entends assez
nul en fait oui mais toi les prix il est
tombé à y est tombé si les noirs qui
sont là sont tombés à meilhan a pris le
dernier pion blanc dako donc parties
nulles
ah oui d'accord les blancs alors à
suivre et blanc n'avaient plus claire
roy maire c'était très très dur y avait
un roi fantômes non mais surtout les
joueurs ont pas placer les pieds sur les
bonnes casse s'est presque pas normal ne
pas les poser sur les bonnes cases
ouais il est lâché très vite et la
plaque pied à terre déséquilibres comme
time 3ds cases sont à cheval évidemment
l'ordinateur sait pas trop où ils sont
et donc il sait pas les positionner donc
c'est pas c'est pas un bug c'est juste
que il sait pas déterminer quelle case
oui car le pathway donc en fait à redire
donc et il est tombé avant de mater
avant de mater je savais plus qui avait
du lot il y avait de refonte en plus de
roger plus ndour qui poursuit voilà le
vide
sachant que ça confirme ce qu'on disait
à la fois romain edouard davantage dans
les yvelines sous les 30 secondes
mais alberto david résiste
voilà donc on est prêt il ya quel parti
c'est très dur à trouver les variantes
quand ça s'accélère
ou quel bliss de folie nous a donnés ici
alberto david qui a quand même sauvé la
mise 1 alors si on s'en tient à ce qui
sauve la mise comme mathieu cornet
depuis le début de ce tournoi
eh bien peut-être que c'est alberto
david qui va l'emporter alors qu'il
aurait pu perdre ce blitz il peut très
bien maintenant remporter le match
il suffit de gagner ce blitz et c'est
fini alors si ce mât celui de ces nuls
mort subite mort subite
on n'a pas le temps de se reposer c'est
parti c'est infernal à une carreaux
cannes car aux quatre variantes avance
donc c'est très à la mode alors qu'on
appelle karo kann alors que quatre des 4
as et le coup ces six là du coup ces six
des 5
donc c'est gênante qui qui est réputé
pour être très solide que joue beaucoup
car pauvre pas beaucoup joué carpeaux
voyez avec les noirs avec les noirs et
donc la une à carreaux cannes moderne
tel qu'il se joue maintenant avec les
blancs les les grands maîtres jouent
tous la variante d' avance maintenant
qu'ils rentrent avec le samu wiki
réputée être la seule pouvant vraiment
essayé de donner
avons quelque chose aux blancs les
autres variantes les noirs s'en sortent
bien
donc quand on va chercher quelque chose
contre l'as cannes c'est la variante
davance aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est de
mouiller et peut-être que voilà dans
deux ans trois ans l'année prochaine
dans six mois un malheur on va trouver
une ligne un malheur qui guy qui
réfutera quel match quel match quel
match et donc le principe dakar au
cannet on passe le fou devant la chaîne
de pions et on est allé solidement un
pion central le pion des 5
c'est la théorie fondamentale est à voir
à ce pion ici un pion ce pion bien très
bien qu'on soudoyés par les noirs et
pour ne pas gêner le fou en la passé
avant d'installer la chaîne voilà les
noirs et on a mis le fout dehors
évidemment de cette chaîne de pions
sinon il aurait été derrière les pions
il aurait été passif si le fou à
villerest était resté sur sa case de
départ on l'a sorti et là maintenant il
est actif et donc ils attaquent le camp
ennemi sinon il aurait été passifs
enfermés derrière ses pions voilà c'est
le l'a senti donc avant de fermer le
cercueil ici par six les noirs une
espèce de forteresse imprenable
le fou de cases noires tient les cases
noires les pions ken les cases blanches
voilà là car aux canaries mais pour être
une grande solidité c5 et de voir romain
edouard là qui essaient de se la joue
positionnelle aussi la comprends mais tu
roules à l'arrêt c'est pour ça que david
a choisi la carro cannes pour pas que
profiteront l'état leur tactique de
haïlé changé d'âme voyez pourquoi tu la
tactique des douars s'exprime il va
prendre la colonna
voilà mais cet avantage ça les noirs
viennent de gagner la colonne à la
control de la colonne à petit avantage
c'est la seule colonne ouverte et c'est
le très important par un petit a qu'une
seule colonne ouverte alors celui qui
qui place
les pièces lourdes où la pièce lourde
qui reste sur cette colonne parce
qu'elle permet des voix d'invasion mois
la colonne a ici voilà cette colonie 6 à
1 à 2 voilà la voie d'invasion on arrive
sur la case à 2 il y aura toujours des
pions qui traînant un jour alors des
comme cette tour est très active
maintenant la table fudzilla le pion b3
maintenant est à la traîne et va falloir
jouer food et un pour le défense à qui
la joue héros f1 il a protégé son fou
maintenant attention le avocat malien a
bola les cavaliers des deux romain
edouard bien vu attention à il attaque
la chaîne de pions wind bien vu il a
émergé avec sk tranquille alors sinon on
peut même temps tenter g5 on pourrait
jouer les 3 donc ce sont les noirs qui
s'est levé il le fait voilà ce sont les
noirs qui sont actifs attaques de chêne
noir son actif en attaque le pur f6 en
attaque le pire on avait joué abscisse
pour pouvoir jouer j'ai ça il va juger
trois ans je pense ça paraît logique
sinon il peut faire pions prend suivi de
pions projet 5 possible aussi oui oui
mais il fait j'ai 3 voilà il a réfléchi
mais finalement il fait g3 donc prise
prise prise prise prise prise voilà toi
tout a été changé
énorme prix d'art ils ont une reprise
laprise larrouy là ça va voilà donc vous
voyez ça s'est simplifié ça va être dur
pour tirer quelque chose de cette danse
au mieux de cette position les lois sont
mieux mais pourquoi cette eau est active
celle là ou correctives mêlant peuvent
très bien puis c'est pitrem le problème
c'est les cavaliers qui n'ont pas de
quelle attention ensemble la menace sans
doute fraîches trois chèques ale le roi
de revenir en général à 2 c pour ça il
empêche le fou noir devenir sur la casa
je crois très important
peut-être que les blancs voient là ils
vont essayer d'améliorer leur mauvaise
pièce lola il veut ramener son cavalier
angers 6 pour vous venir peut-être en h4
faire un petit échec alors c'est
possible aussi qu'il vise la case m5
pour l'ouvrir l'allier un jour c'est
très pénible un qui va jouer corrigé 6
puis sortir le fou récupérer la case f5
pour gérer intéressant concept
positionnait de la part de rom edouard
ils veulent changer le foot 5
voilà donc le cavalier se diriger vers
la case f ça ils remontent
/ il se déploie en même temps voilà il
joue la tour il jouera f7 ensuite il va
sortir le fou est placé le cavalier sur
la case f5
alors en attendant renault faut pas
aller trop vite pas parler de gazon si
on montre pas donc tu parler d'eux d'un
casey 107 quasi si cette case f
et on voit f5 effectivement mais
attention là parce que le leblanc vient
de s'activer et le blanc vient de
récupérer la colonne a ouverte à tous
j'ai attaqué mais cette attaque du pion
mais voilà on peut jouer tout à fait
bien jouer donc j'ai vu toujours la
cible la base de la chaîne ça serait une
erreur audi prend qu'est ce qui se passe
à 1 mais bien sûr surtout au premier set
et bien y aurait il faut échec et une
petite et ensuite une petite astuce
tactique qui parut et remis il n'a pas
vu de prendre le pied en mai 3ème paul
dalla il n'a pas bu voilà donc erreur un
gain d'un pion avantageux alberto david
guez d'un pion pour l'instant petit
point tactiques mais met une pièce ou
non non j'en oublie le fou du puy une
pièce de plus non je mets chèque
attention à la case f5 pour le cavalier
un pas mal échec donc bouge le roi
hockey que ce qu'on peut jouer là il
faut revenir pour supprimer ce cavalier
pour les points 4 roger 4 non parce que
sur wii est une attaque le fou mais
y'aura cavaliers absinthe défend le
fouet et place le cavalier il place les
cavaliers sur vista social club pour
prendre cet échec
attention il y aura chez nous et trois
arrêts et le foot est roi et tant il ya
de fous et trois en l'air il le faut p3
le fouquet trop attention si le football
est roi aussi et voilà et charges
bravo tout reprend cavaliers prendra à
tour prend voilà et tout reprendre
cavaliers le pion des quatre hauts
risques à nanterre le fou ya une pièce
mais bien sûr il permet une fois qu'il a
d'autres pièces va tout d'abord un
retournement encore des situations pièce
incroyable il avait un curriculum la toa
bitumineux 12 contre 2,05 attention par
contient une minute d'avancé on a dit
qu'une minute ça valait largement de pia
oui ça y est il est hétéro vinyle leur
de 0,2 et le roi rentre à leroy rentrer
ou là là et bien gros avantage à romain
edouard medouar en passe de se qualifier
pour la finale du grand prix d'échec
nous bornerons gagnant c'est tout ça
c'est plus de problèmes
une minute 0,8 contre une minute 50
aperto david qui a encore du temps qu'il
a du temps mais mais mais non mais le
curieux est trop faible
et oui il va perdre ce pion est derrière
le pion à venir à faire dame très vite
donc c'est ça va être mat il a largement
le temps de mater alberto romain edouard
il a raté le match tout à l'heure 1
parce qu'il a une embellie va pas le
rater il va pas le rater je pense pas
qu'il le rail largement le temps de
mater il a il est très mal la recherche
une solution ils cherchent un plan
ils cherchent un plan pour tenir donc
dans toute la syrie tuant trois fidèles
rien faire il peut rien faire il a
réussi peut rien faire abattre david
s'est foutu c'est archi faux tu y vas
perdre ce pion et la tour ici protège
l'avancée du pion et donc ensuite le roi
va venir là en plus protéger parce
piolenc il n'y a pas d'échec devrait
pousser pousser et en plus on voit que
le fou contrôler la menace de la ici de
maths c'est fini les analyses king is
brassage et 4,5
ouf c'est fini c'est fini ça est terminé
oui roger pas les pièces regardez bien
cette position et la force du roi qui
est vraiment une pièce d'euros et une
attaque mais qu'elle lui edouard sur
cette île applaudir il jouera la finale
ce soir contre mathieu cornette
[Musique]
oh
m
où
[Musique]